звільнений Ізюм нагадує місто привид на
вулицях майже не лишилося неушкоджених
будівель але біля відділку поліції від
самого ранку людно це люди які шукають
померлих чи зниклих безвісти родичів
серед них і Людмила шукаю свого рідного
сина Київ з них безвісти тіло не знайшли
тіла немає жінка сподівається хоч щось
дізнатися про свого старшого сина
Едуарда він досвідчений військовий
спочатку повномасштабного вторгнення
служив у тероборонні ізюма зв'язок із
хлопцем зник ще в березні в умовах
окупації жінка не наважувалася
розпитувати про долю сина я
переховувалася так і в мене
старший син він мене був готовий
в нього контракта було і Я дуже боялася
що їх всі людей на мене там хтось там
наведуть якусь бо ми не дуже багато
воєнних речей у квартирі всього воєнного
дуже багато і Я дуже боялася два тижні
тому Людмила дізналася що у березні був
авіаналіт на будинок де разом із
старобороною перебував її син військові
розповіли що його завалило уламками
жінка досі не втрачає Надії що син міг
вижити думаємо що може тоді ж росіяни
заходили може його може взяли
[музика]
після звільнення на околицях ізюма
знайшли ось це масове поховання на
могилах хрести з номерами тут виявили
450 тіл ідентифікувати за зовнішніми
ознаками більшості з них уже неможливо
відомо лише що тут поховані і цивільні і
військові деякі із зав'язаними за спиною
руками тепер знайти могили своїх рідних
І підтвердити що там справді поховані
Вони люди можуть лише за результатами
ДНК аналізів ми вже мали ситуації коли в
могилі повинна була бути жінка там був
чоловік могилі повинна була бути одна
людина а в цій могилі було поховано
дві-три людини і ми зараз для того аби
встановити родичів встановити точно
особи загиблих людей
ініціювали активно процес дачі ДНК
матеріалів від родичів аби ми вже мали
юридичні факти і мали кримінальних
провадженнях чітку інформацію щодо осіб
осіб які були за які загинули або було
вбито
спершу з людьми спілкуються слідчі і
прокурори збирають анкетні дані усю
інформацію про загиблих чи зниклих
безвісти це тривалий і кропітки процес у
цій білій машині мобільна лабораторія де
збирають ДНК матеріал Юлія привела
маленьку доньку аби експерти взяли її
зразок жінка сподівається що так
вдасться забрати тіло чоловіка який
помер після мікроінсульту він 20 марта
вмер от його Сначала в дворі похоронили
а потом
россияни перехоронили під номером під
номерами А тепер Як прийшла Україна і
забрали на експертизу Харків результатів
треба буде чекати декілька місяців адже
через завантаженість лабораторій
матеріал відправляють на аналіз в іншій
області Анна принесла на аналіз ДНК
гребінці двох літніх жінок за якими
доглядала хоче по їх по-людськи якраз
ішли прильоти були ми на кладовищі не
були їх поронили без нас Ми все що надо
скупили
хоронили їх без нас нельзя було на той
момент не було Надія Іванова прийшла
здати свій ДНК матеріал щоб знайти
батька коли в Ізюм заїжджали російське
танки вона виїхала з міста разом з
дитиною а батько у якого на тлі
бомбардувань міста стався інсульт
залишився у лікарні невдовзі шпиталь
розбомбили Надія спершу сподівалася що
батько вижив а нині вже знає що їй треба
шукати тіло аби поховати його Я знайшла
лікаря який виїхав
він мені сказав що він загинув там Його
неможливо було
Він сказав що там
[музика]
залишалися ті що там він казав що
у підвалах кого вони
тим часом Людмила дізнається більше
деталей про долю свого зниклого безвісти
сина жінка зустрічається з побратимами
Едуарда які були разом із ним під час
обстрілу бійці не дають Людмилі
сподіватися на краще вони певні що її
син загинув під завалами евакуювати його
під обстрілами не змогли але Припускають
що тіло хлопця могли забрати росіяни які
саме зайшли в місто машина стояла піво
машина а нею витягнули машину кусок
металлолома разорвана блузки машину
витягнули Ну они В любом случае года
стали на жаль при такому авіадарі і де
знаходиться цей хлопець
вмить коли зривалася авіабомба вижати на
у шансі він не мав моя особиста
пересвідчилися він був мер
У Людмили залишився молодший син йому
всього 19 але він так само воював на
Харківщині у боях втратив ногу нині
хлопець на реабілітації Я дуже вдячна що
мене менший син живий я надіюся на
якийсь старший
Людмила ще буде спілкуватися зі слідчими
покази даватимуть і побратими її
зниклого сина поки це Єдине чим вони
можуть допомогти жінці